jean-michel toujours célibataire
toujours alors sophie basso et marié
varier d enfin presque mariée des ans
elle a connu un mec a un nouveau mec
bien dire je vais encore attendre deux
ou trois mois je pense ce sera ça sera
bon je vous posais une question si vous
étiez célibataire louis né dans la
fiction on bascule dans ce qu'on appelle
la fiction dans ce conte bascule assez
entendu l'imaginer est ce que jean
michel maire aurait peu à votre style de
près ou de loin oui ne sont pas trop
désagréable non plus je te comprends le
délire c'est plutôt positif c'est pas
mal eh bien non c'est pas votre nom mais
la famille n'a fait la preuve c'est pas
une réputation qui le précède
ouais c'est ça alors c'est avec les
patrick j'ai aussi des choses ouais je
merci cyril non mais c'est un grand
romantique examen et d'ailleurs qu'est
ce qui s'est passé puisque la semaine
dernière on le saura d'ailleurs demain
dans le dans le pmp le jeu des vérités
ce qui s'est passé avec la jeune fille
avec laquelle vous êtes parti là on
saura tout parce que vous étiez amoureux
la semaine dernière d'une vieille fille
dont la greffière et deux semaines vous
rapprocher de sophie cox et ça on ne
sait plus sur quel pied danser
moi non plus exactement c'est un petit
peu à tous les râteliers ça le problème
il est sensible dans l'amour qu'il le
mérite merci kiliking gravelines de
célibat sophie est ce que de près ou de
loin la star s'il est des mineurs aient
pu être un style maritime je lui demande
qui ce moratoire là non il ya ma
réputation mais non merci
oubli qui paye
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du mec de rihanna élection celle là est
ce qu'on a trouvé une photo du mec de
rien aujourd'hui c'est dingue
j'aurai un bel os tout passer sa
dernière émission c'est ça les
exceptionnels sophie et vous aviez vous
avez une très bon de très bonnes
appréciations sur sophie hier sur
twitter kamal merci parce que c'est une
très bonne camarade et je suis très
content que vous soyez dans l'équipe ou
à partir de combien de logements où on
estimera qu'on a fait le plein puisque
la une de plus soit 1 2 3 ian kelly noah
rebelles tu sais note pascal legrand
qu'est-ce qu'elle a un sérieux elle
normalement c'est tiffany bouchons
tiffany 12 ans elle traite sa mère à
longueur de journée non je veux pas
passer parmentier son beau père ouais tu
seras jamais mon père j'en passe